I got a little piece
of business to do here.
As you know, we just did
a "Sirius Garage Show."
Yeah, that was fun.
That was fun.
It was a lot of fun, I really
think I nailed it and...
Oh, I think we think
we all did a great job.
Yeah, what? Do you have notes for us?
No, no, whatever.
I think both of you will grow by doing.
The more you do it, the better you'll get.
What? (laughs)
But you know, these
shows are made possible
as you know, by Chevrolet.
That's right.
Yeah,
and I have a little nickname for 'em.
I call 'em Chevy.
Oh, that's a cool nickname.
Oh, that's great.
I came up with that this
morning on the way in.
Wow.
That's nice.
I was driving my Chevy and I said,
"Hey, we could call these Chevys,"
and anyway, they have this
amazing lineup of EVs.
You know what EV stands for?
Electronic vehicle.
Oh, I thought it was Evie.
I thought it was electric vehicle.
(laughs) Electronical is what I call it.
Is it electronical?
Yeah.
No, it's absolutely-
It's electric.
They have a great lineup
of electric vehicles.
Okay, there you go.
You're welcome for being here.
And they have sponsored the shows
that we're doing at the Sirius XM Garage.
That's really nice.
That is nice.
And it was nice 'cause it's
an intimate environment.
We get like, 30 people.
30 people is barely an audience as far as,
I mean, I've performed for
tens of thousands of people
in soccer stadiums all across Europe.
Have you? No, you haven't.
C'mon, no.
But these are nice,
intimate special shows.
So to have Chevy there sponsoring us
to get the word out on their EVs,
that's electronical vehicles.
Electric vehicles.
I know, but I like my
way of saying it better.
I know, but it's wrong.
Everyone knows these Chevy brands
but do you know that they're
now available in EVs?
No I didn't know.
What's that stand for?
Electronic vehicles.
Yeah, Chevy's gone all out.
They've got electric charging stations
all over the place now.
That's cool.
Yeah.
Yeah, 'cause you know,
if they didn't have that,
that'd be kind of a problem.
But they do.
They're everywhere.
Well, I mean,
if I had to throw in my two cents,
I'd say Chevy is taking some
of their best known
and most beloved nameplates electric.
So it's not like some random cars
I've never heard of before.
I'd say Chevy has EVs for everyone.
They make electric vehicles for every kind
of life stage and every kind of budget.
Depending on what you wanna spend
and what kind of car you're looking for,
Chevy's got the EV for you.
That's the kind of thing I would say.
What would you say off the
top of your head, Sona?
Let's switch one.
(Matt laughing)
You like an EV?
I do.
I would say, you know,
Chevy is the brand you trust
and they are very available
and you can go get them.
And guess what?
What's that?
For Mikey and Charlie,
your two kids?
Yes.
I'm sure they have a great family car
that you could buy.
Okay, good.
I wish I knew which one, but-
Do they still have the Chevette?
Oh, Silverado.
Man, what a cool name.
That's the best.
Isn't that the coolest name for a vehicle?
What you got there?
Silverado.
Oh man.
That's great.
Wish I was the voice of Chevy.
(Sona laughing)
Give it a shot.
Silverado EV.
[Matt] That's pretty good.
If you want an EV, get a Silverado.
Well now you're just like a smokin' wino.
It sounds like you have an issue,
like a sickness.
(Matt laughing)
All right.
Well, anyway.
You sound like you're about to say,
"Wanna know how I got these scars?"
(all laughing)
You're in a no smoking commercial.
(Sona laughing)
Hey listen.
Can I borrow your clothes?
(all laughing)
I used to have pants.
Chevy.
You know, if I was listening
to this ad right now, I'd be saying,
"Hey, in a very funny and charming way,
they've piqued my interest
about Chevrolet's electronic vehicles."
Yes.
Okay? Mm-hm.
And I'd wanna know more.
I'd say to learn more
about the all-electric Chevy EV lineup,
head to chevrolet.com/conan.
Make sure you're following @TeamCoco
for behind-the-scenes content
from these live shows and much, much more.
And remember, my favorite
truck is the Silverado.
'Rado, 'rado, 'rado.
(Conan laughing)
That doesn't work.
You know they have an
effect that can do that.
Yeah, it's called, it's called me.
(all laughing)
How do you think I got
started in this game?
ado, -ado.